video hinter mir auf dem screen das
zeigt lagerarbeiter rippberg ashraf in
einem kleinen kiosk kaufte er sich nach
feierabend noch etwas ein doch die
aufnahmen dahin zu mir das sind die
letzten bilder von ihm denn auf dem
nachhauseweg fällt plötzlich ein
unbekannter über ihn her und ermordeten
andreas wegner berichtet
ein paar flaschen bier ein freundliches
gespräch ein winken zum abschied ein
normaler feierabend für etwa karin
kaspar doch die nacht des 26
august 2020 wird er nicht überleben
wenige minuten nach diesen aufnahmen
über triebwerk ashraf brutal ermordet
hierauf diesem verbindungsweg hatte er
den wohnungsschlüssel schon in der hand
war fast zu hause war da kam plötzlich
der killer und stach unvermittelt mit
äußerster brutalität auf ihn ein die
rechtsmediziner stellen bei der
obduktion
44 messerstiche fest einige waren sogar
ins gesicht gegangen seine nachbarin
eine krankenschwester findet den
37-jährigen familienvater
blutüberströmt auf den gehweg jede hilfe
kommt zu spät sie kann nur noch seinen
tod feststellen debug ashrafs killer
verschwand in der dunkelheit und kommt
ungestraft davon
die vag ashraf vater eines vierjährigen
sohnes ist im kiosk ein bekannter kunde
der 37 jährige lagerarbeiter kommt dort
jeden abend vorbei und kaufte sein
feierabendbier
vom kiosk bis zur e bass wohnung in der
der familienvater seit der trennung von
seiner frau lebt sind es keine zehn
minuten weniger als einen kilometer geht
er durch die nacht kurz vor seiner
haustür nimmt der 37-jährige eine
abkürzung eine fatale entscheidung mit
tödlichen folgen die ermittler befragen
die arbeitskollegen des 37-jährigen
seine freunde und bekannten erfolglos
das rätsel um rewag ashrafs mord bleibt
ungelöst und der täter auf der flucht
bis jetzt mehr als ein jahr nach der
brutalen hinrichtung des irakers stehen
die ermittler kurz vor dem durchbruch
die ermittlungen der polizei
konzentrieren sich zunächst auf eine
dunkle gestalt die zeugen hier in der
nähe des tatorts gesehen hatten jetzt
ergab sich aber noch eine weitere spur
und zwar konnte eine einzelne dna spur
an der leiche festgestellt werden die
einer frau zuzuordnen ist und somit
stellt sich den ermittlern der
mordkommission jetzt die frage ob
möglicherweise eine frau diesen brutalen
mord begangen hat für die dna spur zu
mutmaßlichen messer mörderin von red
back ashraf weitere zeugen berichten von
einem streit in unmittelbarer nähe des
tatorts wir haben jetzt vor kurzem noch
einen zeugenhinweis bekommen der kurz
vor dem tatgeschehen eine weibliche
stimme gehört hat die eine andere person
laut angeschrien hat in einer
ausländischen sprache kannte er rät war
carina schwab seinen killer war es ein
verbrechen aus leidenschaft oder aus
blankem hass die fahndung läuft wir
haben belohnungen ausgegeben 5000 euro
sind für hinweise auf den täter
ausgelobt worden
[Musik]